hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast illuminating the
druggable GP crm presented by brian L
Roth Michael hooker distinguished
professor Department of Pharmacology and
division of chemical biology and
medicinal chemistry
asalaam School of Pharmacy I'm Alexis
Krause of laberd's and I'll be our
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab birds
labret is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the
accreditation button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen and follow the process to
obtain your credits please joining me in
welcoming dr. Roth I will now turn the
presentation over to him thank you very
much happy to be here today and as was
mentioned today I'm going to speak about
the druggable
gpcr oh and before I start I would just
like to say that a lot of this work has
been done in my lab and in collaboration
with Brian Shaw ket's lab at UCSF and
all of the work that I'm presenting
today is sponsored by the National
Institute of Health primarily through a
new initiative eliminating the druggable
genome and our particular project
relates to g-protein coupled receptors
one one final bit of housekeeping here
I'm in the School of Medicine as well as
the School of Pharmacy at UNC Chapel
Hill so today what I'm going to talk
about our g-protein coupled receptors
and new advances in drug discovery and
target development and just by way of
background on g-protein coupled
receptors represent the largest family
of druggable targets in the human genome
this is a pie chart of the genome
published many years ago still a very
current and what you can see from this
is that g-protein coupled receptors
which number around 900 represent
approximately 4% of the DNA the open
reading frames that are encoded by the
human genome and by far and away
represent the largest family of
druggable targets in the human genome
and g-protein coupled receptors coupled
to multiple signaling pathways they are
seven transmembrane domain proteins here
you can see on the left-hand side
following agonist binding a
conformational change occurs leading to
the dissociation of their heterotrimeric
g protein and activation of various
downstream effectors in this case this
is a G alpha Q coupled g-protein coupled
receptor activates plc leading to the
release of inositol triphosphate and
ultimately the mobilization of
intracellular calcium and this is what
is generally called canonical
g-protein coupled receptor signaling
following that the receptors are
phosphorylated arrest ins find and
arrest ins have two functions the first
is to stop signaling through G proteins
hence the name arrested and secondly
they serve as scaffolds for various
downstream effectors most notably
members of the RAF mek or kinase pathway
and this causes another type of
signaling which is different in kinetic
and texture from canonical g-protein
signaling and has opened the possibility
for ultimately tailoring drugs which
activate g-protein signaling versus
arrested and vice versa which may have
better efficacy and fewer side effects
than currently available medications now
my lab is involved mainly in structure
function studies of g-protein coupled
receptors as well as drug discovery
related to them and by way of background
around twenty years ago my lab received
a large program funded by the National
Institute of Health which is a small
molecule drug discovery program and if
we can just go back here one slide one
of the nice things about g-protein
coupled receptors is that they coupled
to multiple downstream signaling
pathways and this is is helpful not only
for discovering drugs which activate
various pathways but also for devising
assays with which to screen gpcr so
they're very easy to screen and because
of this we some years ago set up a
parallel screening platform which allows
us to screen large numbers of molecular
targets focused mainly on g-protein
coupled receptors in a highly parallel
fashion and this schematically shows how
that's done basically every plate would
get a different receptor and then we
would screen relatively sort of modest
libraries of small molecules against
them and over the years this has
resulted in a large number of very
important findings which are summarized
in in many of these papers and some of
these we'll be discussing today and I
think part of the success of this
program has been the fact that our lab
uses a rather unusual
a novel form of screening which we call
massively parallel screening where
hundreds of targets will be interrogated
simultaneously rather than the typical
approach which is to take sort of a
single receptor here in screen large
numbers of compounds against it now one
of the one of the nice things about
g-protein coupled receptors and studying
them as I as I mentioned before and I'm
going to use the acronym gpcrs going
forward is that they're the largest
family of druggable targets in the human
genome
there are around 400 what are called non
olfactory GPCRs in the human genome
perhaps a third of approved and
investigational drugs act on g-protein
coupled receptors as their primary
target and interestingly enough in
addition to the 30% of approved
medications which have GPCRs as their
primary target most drugs and and
reagents that that are used in in cell
biology and chemical biology
investigation in addition to approved
medications have important off-target
actions at GPCRs and this includes many
selective kinase inhibitors and of the
of this entire family of GPCRs which we
call the GPC our own a large portion of
it is under study and just to illustrate
this and the importance of this for drug
discovery both the known as well as the
under studying GPCRs I'd like to take
you through a little project that I
conducted about a year or so ago and
basically what I did is I took the list
of fda-approved medications they were
curated by myself for their canonical
target and I also looked at a list of
drugs that were in development and this
was from a recent issue of Nature
Reviews drug discovery and also curated
them and I mapped them onto a tree of
gpcrs and that's shown here and this was
published in sell a few months ago and
what you can see here
is that although there are many many
drugs that target GPCRs they in essence
target just a handful of the Nolan G
protein-coupled receptors so you can see
some receptors here like histamine
receptors mustard receptors dopamine
receptors have large numbers of drugs
targeted to them but most gpcrs in the
genome that are certainly druggable have
very few if any GPC drugs targeted them
and in fact around 90% of gpcrs have
absolutely no drugs targeted them at all
and that's the same not only for drugs
that are already approved but for drugs
and development and if you do the same
exercise looking at drugs that are in
various stages of Blake preclinical and
early clinical development these target
perhaps 30% of the drug level gpcr owns
so we have a large portion of the
druggable genome which is potentially a
ripe for drug discovery looking at it
another way what I what I did was I went
through and did a PubMed search of
essentially all of the druggable GPCRs
in the human genome and simply added
added up the number of citations for
every GPCR and then plotted it here
against every gpcr in the genome and
basically what you can see here is a
bimodal distribution where about half of
the GPCRs in the genome have hundreds to
thousands of papers devoted to them
whereas another half have less than 100
papers and a lot of these have just a
few and if you dig down into this into
this under study area you'll find of
these hundred or so papers most of them
are either review articles or
genome-wide Association studies which
simply lists the name of a gene PCR and
have no particular scientific
information associated with them so a
large number of these are under study
as well as being underutilized in terms
of drug discovery if you look at it a
third way in here again we're looking at
a phylogenetic tree of the GPRO and what
I've done here is I have simply
tabulated the number of small molecules
that are that have been annotated in the
chemistry literature against various
members of the gpcr superfamily and
wherever there's a large circle what
this means is that few if any small
molecules or drugs have been annotated
against that particular p PCR yeah where
there's a small circle this means that
hundreds or thousands of small molecules
have been annotated against them and
what you can see is that some receptors
for example the biogenic amine receptors
for instance have thousands of small
molecules targeted against them
most of the GPCRs in the genome actually
have very few if any small molecules
that are targeted against them so again
this is a huge area potentially very
valuable for therapeutic drug discovery
so we taking advantage of this we coined
the term hoe GPCRs for understudied and
orphan GPCRs those GPCRs which for which
there's very little information and
these primarily are the part are going
to be the subject of today's talk for
the end of the talk I'll I'll talk about
some more well-known gpcrs but we know
from expression studies and precedent
they should have important roles in
signaling and physiology and we believe
most of them actually are druggable from
a drug discovery perspective and
unfortunately most of them have no known
ligands the signaling pathways are
unknown and this can make screening
difficult in addition to not knowing
much
these particular receptors what we and
others have found is that much of the
published data even about the
understudied GPCRs are difficult to
replicate and this is because they're
very complex and sensitive to assay
conditions in unpredictable ways and
finally just by nature of the fact that
GPCRs are involved in signaling and
there's a high degree of redundancy
knockout or genetic deletion of
individual gpcrs frequently has little
if any growth phenotype making studying
them by emerging genetic technologies
like CRISPR problematic and just to
illustrate the of the potential
importance of these orphan and
understudy GPCRs therapeutically
relevant targets I want to point out a
few discoveries which you can see in one
of our recent papers where these
understudy GPCRs turned out to be
extremely important for therapeutic
and/or side effects of known medications
for example in the upper left hand side
you can see that erythromycin and
certain side effects related to
macrolide antibiotics have been revealed
to be due to the modal and receptor a
very serious therapy side effects of
fergus and appetite suppressing
medications were involved found to be
involved with with a particular
understudy serotonin receptor
benzodiazepines which are commonly used
for treating anxiety have important
effects at an orphan receptor GP r88
drugs like morphine which are used
widely for treatment of pain many of
their side-effects now appeared to be
mediated through a understudied gpcr
called MRG prx2
and so on and if if you're interested in
in these and other findings i urge you
to read the review article that's listed
there and shown here
now for the rest of the talk what I'd
like to do is spend most of it
explaining how we then interrogate these
understudy GPCRs and first I'll tell you
about a platform that we recently
revealed which allows for genome-wide
screening of the entire family of these
receptors and then a computational
pipeline that we have built I then like
to show you this works in practice using
libraries of annotated small molecules
and finally I'd like to show you how we
can use x-ray crystal structures to
discover new ligands for both studied as
well as under study GPCRs so if we go to
the first part of the talk
large-scale discovery of ligands for
these under study GPCRs I just want to
give a shout out to the people in my lab
that were involved in this you can see
them there Wes shiping Florey and Vince
were the main drivers of this particular
endeavor and so as I mentioned at the
very beginning of this talk GPCR
signaling is very complicated they can
single through a number of G proteins
and it's frequently difficult to
determine in advance which particular G
protein or signal pathway particular
GPCR might signal through but what we
know is that virtually all of them also
have important interactions with
arresting and we took advantage of this
to devise a pay basically a platform
where we can screen the entire GP CRM
essentially in a single 384-well plate
and the assay that we used we borrowed
from or took inspiration from a platform
that was developed by Richard in Richard
Axel's lab by Gilead Barnea which uses
beta arrested as a platform basically
what you have is
engineered GPCR with a tail which has
been engineered to be a very high
affinity binding site for arresting and
following ligand binding there's
translocation of a arrested temp
protease chimeric protein this allows
the release of a transcriptional
activator which then activates the tet
transcriptional machinery in engineered
cells ultimately leading to luciferase
as a readout then this basically yields
light and for those in the audience that
have been involved in screening know
that luciferase is a very and and
luciferase based assays are extremely
robust and very sensitive and Ganesa
easily be done in 384 and higher well
formats in over the years
as you can see from those references my
lab has used this platform basically in
a single GPCR by GPCR application and
simply because this this assay worked so
well what we decided to do was to see if
we could exemplify this platform across
the entire GP CRO to essentially make it
Universal as a platform for GPCRs the
way we did this was we used a modular
design strategy where we took the open
reading frames of GPCRs which is notated
here as GPCRs CES and then place them in
a module that consisted of various
epitope tags the basal press entail that
have pretty a site and the
transcriptional activator and the
individual GPCRs were then synthesized
by synthetic DNA technology company and
overall around 90% of the nono factory
GPCRs were synthesized this includes
virtually all the orphaned GPCRs and
they were expressed at at very high
levels
the cell surface and we performed
intensive validation on those for which
there are known ligands and and as you
can see this was published a couple
years ago and this gives you a sense of
the validation so in the upper left hand
corner is an overview of the platform in
the upper right hand corner you can see
untranslated cells or cells that are
transfected with two sort of random
orphan gpcrs and see very high levels of
expression and then in the bottom two
panels we can see on the left-hand side
how signaling through the assay works
the arrested based tango platform or
through canonical signaling through
calcium and you can see for both for
this particular understudied receptor
which is a neural mean B receptor very
very nice level of signaling very nice
dose response and signal to noise and
overall if we map the entire platform
against the entire g/e CRO wherever
there's a colored circle is is basically
where we have a validated assay and you
can see with the exception of the
adhesion and the taste of receptors we
have essentially saturation coverage of
the entire GP CRM and just to give you a
sense of how useful this is we did a
study where we screen 91 of these under
study GPCRs against a small panel of
approved medications and this shown on
the left is a heat map of those data you
can see a relatively sparse heat map
which is good it means that there's not
a lot of promiscuous activity you can
see a couple of bands going across which
represent essentially promiscuous
compounds but if we screen in or zoom in
to a certain area of the heat map you
can see how sparse this matrix is if we
blow this up you'll see that this
Red Square corresponds to the activation
of a particular orphan GPCR in this case
one called mrgp rx4 by the drug from tag
lemma the tag line I'd mountain at Eglin
I'd an interesting drug it's approved to
channel modulator gaseum channel
modulator approved for use in metabolic
disorders but it has side effects of
itch and we believe that the side
effects of itch actually are probably
due to off target interactions with this
understudy gpcr mrgp RX for now this is
now available as resource it allows
unbiased screening of the entire
druggable genome GP crm in a single 384
well plate
it's robust and scalable it allows for
the identification of novel targets for
known drugs and drug like compounds and
one of the things that we've done is
we've made this resource available via
edging so it's open-source and to date
around 8,000 orders have been shared by
a gene in my lab doesn't make any money
with this it's something that that we
have provided to the scientific
community at a nominal fee through
edging one of the other things that this
this and related platforms have allowed
us to do is is is to re-examine issues
of selectivity versus promiscuity and
this comes from a recent paper where we
contributed to a study of a number of
quote unquote selective protein kinase
inhibitors and the heat map of their
activity against the chi node can be as
shown in the blue graph on the left and
a corresponding heat map of their
activity against a subset of the GPC RM
is shown on the right you see that even
though many of these compounds are
reasonably selective for a kinase as
they have very promiscuous off target
actions at gpcrs and in many cases this
can be in the single-digit nano molar
level and this is likely very important
not only for side effects of protein
kinase but potentially for their
therapeutic actions as well so what I'm
going to do next is show you that now
that we have these platforms available
how you can use these platforms of
highly in combination of libraries of
highly annotated small molecules to
infer functions and identify drugs for
these under study gpcrs I'm going to
essentially go over two papers that have
been published in the last couple of
years the first paper in Nature just
published a little over two years ago
and the approach we took for this paper
was twofold so it initially what we did
was to do a small molecule screen
against a large number of understudied
gpcrs as as I showed you earlier when we
had done the tag Lanai and what we found
in this screen was that certain drugs in
the benzodiazepine family had reasonably
high affinity for a orphan GPCR called
GP our 68 efforts to optimize these
benzo days of being derivatives to probe
like or to like small molecules was was
on basically unsuccessful and so what we
did is we took a computational approach
and this is the approach that I'm going
to tell you about for for the next a
little bit of the talk and this was
pioneered by Brian Shaw and ket's lab
with a very talented graduate student
jolt RP AK and essentially what he did
was we had initial chemical matter for
this particular orphan GPCR GPR 68 we
had no structures for it but there were
structures available for a
family member which had some degree of
similarity in this case around 29% a
large number of models were then built
using homology to cxcr4 using the
program modeler and total 3,300 diverse
homology models were built these were
then used to select a four compounds
that were known to interact with this
receptor as well as four compounds that
were known not to interact with them
further to pick among the various models
and then mutagenesis and further
modeling was performed to identify a
putative binding site for a drug
discovery within the receptor and that's
shown here so essentially what we what
we realized in the course of the
modeling and the initial probe discovery
was that there was likely a two types of
sites and allosteric was called an
allosteric site for drugs which are
specific for this particular receptor as
well as another site for hydrogen ions
which in normal cells target this
receptor and that's called the
orthostatic site armed with this
knowledge Joel performed a large-scale
docking campaign and in total around
three million compounds were docked
against the receptor targeting these
various domains and in the first round
of docking compounds like those at the
bottom of the screen appeared these were
then tested against GP r68 those that
were active were then used to seeing
search for new compounds which led to
compounds in the middle and this process
was repeated
again and yielded compounds like those
near the top and that particular
compound turned out to be a positive
allosteric modulator for GPR 68 which we
dubbed Oberon and the reason for this is
that GPR 68 at one time was known as OGG
r1 or ovarian cancer related gpcr one so
we dumped it Oh Guren
now Holdren is a very unusual compound
in that it doesn't directly activate the
receptor but it's a positive allosteric
modulator against the native ligand
which in this case is hydrogen ions so
you can see when we graph activation of
the receptor versus pH which is shown
here in the in the black circles at the
bottom that's the native activation of
the receptor by hydrogen ions and in the
presence of increasing concentrations of
Ogrin which we have with the shown with
the red arrow there is an increase in
the potency and the efficacy of GPR 68
to be activated so this indicates that
this is a true positive allosteric
modulator and what was gratifying to us
is that the final probe compound or very
little structural similarity to the know
and allosteric modulator zuv GPR 68 that
we had uncovered in our small molecule
screen drugs like lorazepam also known
as atom an and des methyl diazepam which
is a derivative value not only is the
compound active activating GPR 68 in
cell culture we also found it was active
in activating GPR 68 in vivo in this
case we used a contextual fear
conditioning
assay because GPR 68 is known to be in
in the hippocampus you can see that in
wild-type mice Oberon reduces contextual
fear conditioning but has absolutely no
effect GPR 68 knockout mice and it was
also inactive on related gpcrs as well
as other GPCRs in the genome in active
and control cells and active on gaba
receptors as predicted had weak very
weak activity at adenosine to a
receptors but importantly provides a
role for GPR 68 in learning since it
affects contextual fear conditioning and
provides a tool to modulate GPR 68 so
that shows our our pipeline which is a
combination of a physical screening as
well as computational I want to give one
more example here of how how this
pipeline works in practice this is a
from a more recent paper we studied we
published which relates to this very
interesting family of receptors the mrgp
RX family of receptors now this is a
interesting family of orphan receptors
they get their name mrgp RX from the
mass related g-protein coupled receptor
family they're called ex because they're
primate exclusive they're not found in
in mouse or rats or other other rodents
they're expressed at very high levels in
the dorsal root ganglia as well as mast
cells and other immune cells and they've
been linked to to pain and itch and we
as I mentioned we had this tango assay
platform and we decided to use this to
see if we could identify initial
chemical matter for MRG prx2 and
ultimately to identify tool compounds
and as I mentioned this is exclusive to
the transfected receptor is scalable and
very robust so our approach was
to take a relatively small library of
compounds in this case a 6800 were
screened against various members of the
mrgp rx family actives were then
validated and concentration response
curves and then based on orthogonal
assays and ligand structure we began to
infer things like receptor properties
function and off target drug effects so
this is the result of our small molecule
screen we were able to find actives for
three members of this family mrgp are X
1 X 2 and X 4 you can see there was some
overlap between the 3 mrgp our X 2 had
the largest number of active compounds a
little over 80 and that was the one that
we focused on it's a G alpha Q coupled
gpcr there are no known selective small
molecule ligands it has a role in
sensory neurons but is unknown and also
is known to induce degranulation in mast
cells and what are the interesting
things that we found was that commonly
prescribed medications like opioids as
well as opioid like drugs tended to
activate mrgp rx 2 and you can see a
couple of the scaffolds that we
discovered and when we looked at a large
number of opioid medications as well as
opioids small molecules and natural
products we found an interesting SAR so
these are all technically more fine and
drugs and compounds that had relatively
small substituents there on the on the
methyl group on the morphine and ring
tended to be active whereas those that
have larger substituents tended to be
inactive and the fact that there was
this very clear-cut SAR and association
with a particular scaffold led us to
believe that or gave us
confidence that this was a real
interaction as I mentioned a number of
more finance and whorfin and like
compounds had potency for MRG prx2
none of them were selective and we were
never able to drive the potency down
into the nano molar range which we need
for a useful tool compound but the fact
that that we had a large number of
compounds led us to believe that we
could use the same approach that that we
had used with GPR 68 to find a potential
tool compounds for so again what we did
is we made it or Joel made a model for
the four mrgp rx 2 in this case we can
line into the cap opiate receptor by
then we have large numbers of compounds
we can dock against the various models
as well as decoys this led to a
optimized model for ligand recognition
for which we did site-directed
mutagenesis to verify the model and then
once we had the model we were then able
to dock 6 million lead light compounds
against the receptor this led to the
initial identification of micro molar
potency compounds and ultimately some
micro molar compounds you can see here
zinc 9 2 3 2 as well as a matched pair
matched in active analog which is I'll
show you
we're active against mrgp Rx in vitro
and in vivo
so this basically shows that mrgp rx 2
can be activated by this tool compound
for both non canonical or arrested
signaling as well as canonical signal
signaling it's a GQ coupled receptor
through intracellular calcium release
1067 was a control compound in DMSO of
courses vehicle as I mentioned mrgp rx 2
in humans is found in mass cells and
mast cells
induce degranulation in in exposure to
allergens and this leads to histamine
release so many of the symptoms that you
or your relatives may experience
seasonal rhinitis colds allergies etc
are due to histamine release from mast
cells it turns out that mast cells are
very useful system to evaluate MRG prx2
because they are expressed endogenously
and so we decided to use the lab 2 cell
which is human mast cell line which
endogenously Russ's mrgp RX 2 and
measured intracellular calcium release
as well as the release of beta hexose a
minute days which is a measure of mast
cell degranulation and when we measured
beta hexosaminidase release you can see
that our our tool compound was
reasonably potent at activating it along
with other compounds that were known to
have activity and interestingly enough
for both plus and minus morphine and
these results were very consistent with
our data that we obtained with
transfected HEK cells and one of the
things that's known about mrgp RX 2 is
that agonist promote degranulation in a
non I GE dependent fashion and that's
basically shown here and finally that
based on all of this information we
proposed that this might be the
mechanism for a previously known and
widely reported opioid drug effect so
it's knowing for instance that people
that take opioids like morphine and so
on in addition to the beneficial effects
of opioids frequently have itching so
it's called pure itis
and this has been known for decades and
recently say the last 20 years or so has
been known to be induced by morphine and
similar medications but not mediated by
canonical opioid receptors and some of
the strongest evidence for that is
because the drug codeine which itself is
inactive it codeine actually has to be
metabolized to morphine and induced mast
cell degranulation so it doesn't affect
opiate receptors but requires g-proteins
so so what we think basically is that
this receptor MRG prx2 is the
long-sought itch receptor mediated which
mediates many of the side effects of
opioids we think that medications that
target this might be very effective for
treating pain and itch as I mentioned
one of the main approaches we're using
now is to use computational docking to
identify new ligands for orphan and
understudy gpcrs i just want to give a
shout-out to my collaborators of
Braunschweig cath lab they have built a
database called zinc it's entirely in
the public domain up until a couple of
years ago it had six million compounds
in stock for docking there now are over
160 million compounds in available in a
few years there will be more than a
billion compounds available for
computational docking so those of you
that are interested in these
technologies please check out their site
sinked org so what I showed you in the
in the first main part of my talk was
how we can use advanced computational
approaches as well as small molecule
drug discovery which is enabled by new
screening technologies to find drug like
compounds for these understudy GPCRs as
you may know over the last few years
there have been a number of GPCRs for
which high resolution crystal structures
have been published many from my lab and
my collaborators and I just like to give
you a brief view on how we might use
these crystal structures to identify a
new ligands what I'm going to do is just
highlight a recent paper that was
published in science just a couple of
months ago where we solved the structure
of the d4 dopamine receptor so dopamine
is a very important neurotransmitter
it's involved in virtually all of the
rewarding stimuli rewarding properties
virtually all stimuli drugs alcohol sex
Twitter and so on this regulation of
dopaminergic neurotransmission is also
involved in a number of diseases
Parkinson's disease other basal ganglia
disorders schizophrenia virtually all
psychiatric disorders there are five
dopamine receptors in the genome if you
go to chemical databases thousands of
compounds are annotated against them in
large numbers of papers in PubMed but
despite all this interest in dopamine
and dopamine receptors creating subtypes
selective Linkens has proved challenging
and what we found when we obtained the
first high-resolution view of a dopamine
receptor was that there and this is just
a summary of that structure down to one
point nine five angstroms was that there
was this interesting water network
stabilizing receptor you can see the
electron density maps here were very
very high indicating very high level
resolution but the interesting thing
from a drug discovery perspective was
that when we compared this structure
with a previous relatively low
resolution structure of related receptor
d3
found that there was a new extended
binding pocket here for the drug that we
used to solve the structure here which
was unique for the d4 receptor and it
was not found in the d3 and I just want
to draw your attention to this because
we last week published in nature the
structure of the d2 receptor and we find
that that this extended binding pocket
is also not found in the d2 receptor so
given the fact that there's this
extended binding pocket it really opened
up the possibility that we could use
this pocket to identify new new and
selective ligands for the d4 receptor so
what was done again we went to our
collaborators Brian showed ket's lab in
this case an app Levin and she talked a
little over a million compounds against
the structure of the d2 receptor in
total this was trillions of complexes
and high high scoring compounds scored
by the docking algorithm were then
obtained and tested and you can see in a
typical screen here on the right around
three of the ten or so compounds so
about a 30% hit rate were obtained these
compounds the best of these compounds
which we call compound 9 was then taken
with an iterative strategy that involved
analog screen and redocking and in total
a number of compounds were obtained for
that screen two distinct chemo types
were found compound 9 - 6 and 9 - 11
these were then as you can see a higher
affinity in this case 30 to 60 nano
molar an analog screen and redocking was
done and this led to our final compound
9 - 6 - 24 which now has a single-digit
animal potency and is ten thousandfold
selective against the d4 receptor so you
can see in a relatively straightforward
process we were able to go from micro
molar compounds to single digit Nana
compounds in this case without any
chemistry all these compounds were
commercially available so the highlights
of this structure it's the highest
resolution structure of a biogenic and
beam receptor the first GPCR that was
crystallized with and without explicit
sodium the extended binding pocket
revealed residues essential for receptor
subtype selectivity and I yielded a
platform which yield a new chemical
matter for the D for dopamine receptor
and so that's all I want to say today I
want to thank you very much for
listening I just want to highlight
people in my lab who did this work the
first part of the talk was done headed
up by Wes sheep ring and the second part
was done by Kate primarily with wes's
help and our collaborators Brian show
Chet and Joel cardiac and the d4
receptor structure was done with Shang
and a Nath Leavitt also wanted knowledge
the funding NIH eliminating the
druggable genome and then Kate had a
grant from the pharma Foundation and
thank you very much I'm happy to answer
any questions you may have
Thank You dr. Roth for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you asked please do so now just
click on the ask a question drop-down
box located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many questions as we have time for and
so let's get started our first question
is can you tell me about how to access
the screening program yeah so that's a
good question so the the easiest way to
access it is to simply top type my name
into Google Brian Roth and you'll go to
our website it's the NIH psychoactive
drug screening center and if you if you
basically go there there's a basically a
very nice menu that provides all sorts
of information on on how you might
obtain screening we have an online
database which is has been very popular
we get about a million hits a month and
and other information there now second
the other thing I might I might mention
is that the screening is available to
anyone who is funded by the National
Institute of Health it's paid for with
the grant that we have from the NIH and
screening is entirely free and
confidential so it's a really good deal
so next question our next question is
what are the new frontiers in gpcr drug
discovery so I would say there are two
so one one frontier that I mentioned a
lot in this particular talk is with the
really the revolution that's ongoing and
you can see our structure determination
we're now able to take advantage of
these structures and use very advanced
computational approaches to find new
chemical matter
the receptors and so many many labs are
doing that I think this is a very active
area and as I mentioned currently we're
able to access a basis basically
libraries of small molecules that are
virtual of a hundred hundred plus
million compounds so way more than could
ever be screened in a physical way the
other big area of gpcr research
currently and the frontier is relates to
bias signalling I didn't I didn't go
into that to any extent in the talk but
if you remember at the beginning of the
talk I mentioned there are these broadly
speaking two pathways of GPCR signaling
through g-protein and arresting it's
becoming clear that activating one
pathway over the other may be very
important either for side effects or
therapeutic effects of both approved and
candidate medications and so the idea is
that if we can take make drugs that
target either the arresting pathway or
the g-protein pathway we might be able
to make safer and more effective
medication so I would say that's that's
the other frontier the third of course
there are these understudied GPCRs we
you know don't know anything about them
really any any new information is likely
to be very important going forward and
it looks like we have time for one more
question what if you don't have a GPCR
structure right so as I mentioned if you
don't have a structure what we can do is
we can do computational modeling and as
was exemplified in the talk and one of
the nice things about about that
approach as well as the approaches that
I that I mentioned here is all of these
resources modeler which is used to make
the models sink the zinc library which
is a source of the of the compounds and
then the program dock which is used to
dock the compounds as well as our
screening resources these are all now
available in the public domain without
really any restrictions to use by
academic investigators so
particularly the computational
approaches actually can can be used
remotely so if you if you simply have
access to a PC or a Mac and the Internet
you can you can actually use these
resources to create your own models and
then do the docking you know potentially
in your own in your own home without
without a biopsy is that the technology
is has really become quite user friendly
I would like to once again thank dr.
Roth for his presentation I would also
like to thank leverets for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to look everyone
know that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May of 2018 you will receive an email
from laberd's letting you know when this
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon goodbye